في كلمه القاها عشيه الجوله الحاسمه من
الانتخابات قال اردوغان خلال زياره لضريح
رئيس الوزراء الراحل عدنان مندريس والذي
اطيح به في انقلاب عام 1960 قال ان هذا
الانقلاب لم يحرم الشعب التركي من
الديمقراطيه فقط بل ترك جرحا غائرا في
وجدانه
[موسيقى]
نقف اليوم في ذكرى احد اكثر الايام حركه
في تاريخ جمهوريتنا ففي مثل هذا اليوم قبل
63 عاما تعرضت تركيا لاول انقلاب عسكري في
تاريخها لم يحرم شعبنا من الديمقراطيه
والتنميه فقط بل ترك ايضا جرحا غائرا في
قلوبنا نؤكد ان التصويت الكبير وحجم
المشاركه في الانتخابات يؤكد حرص امتنا
على حمايه مستقبلها واستقلالها عبر
الديمقراطيه
من جهتي وجه مرشح تحالف الشعب التركي كمال
كرشدا في العاصمه انقره وجهه انتقاداتي
للحكومه بسبب ادائها الاقتصادي الذي وصفه
بالضعيف والذي اضر بالعائلات التركيه
ومنعها من تقديم الغذاء الصحي والرعايه
لاطفالها على حد تعبيره
على الدوله ان تكون اجتماعيه وان تقف الى
جانب العائلات هذه وظيفه الدوله وليس
الافراد والمنظمات على الدوله الاجتماعيه
الا تترك عائلاتها في عوز للاخر وعليها ان
تنشئ الحضانات لصالح الامهات العاملات في
الاحياء الفقيره لان ذلك من مميزات الدوله
الاجتماعيه عند وصولنا للحكم سنمنح كل
عائله محتاجه مبلغا شهريا ونعد بعدم قطع
خدمات الماء والكهرباء او الغاز عن اي
عائله محتاجه في تركيا